oh goody time now for our seen and
unseen I've been do seen an unseen
segment tonight where we expose what's
really going on behind the big cultural
stories of the day but what's in a name
well a lot of you believe there's a lot
in the name Boy Scouts but not for much
longer
for that and so much more we're joined
here by New York Times bestselling
author and Fox News contributor Raymond
Arroyo Raymond do not tell me the Boy
Scouts are gonna be called what now
because girls are this venerable
institution founded in 1907 by Robert
baden-powell he was a British officer in
India who realized his men didn't know
basic first-aid or survival skills so he
created a book on scouting it caught on
after a hundred and eight years the Boy
Scouts are now going to be known as
scouts BSA because they've included
girls in their ranks BSA Boy Scouts Boy
Scouts oh yeah but it's just Scouts but
some people are saying it should be
scout two Bs because it's now okay
that's what I thought of course you did
of course you did but it is causing now
the CEO of the Boy Scouts loves this
he's out celebrating it as you might
expect this is an exciting day for the
Boy Scouts of America we have a new
opportunity to serve young women in a
way that we have not done before we've
had co-ed programs for over 40 years so
we have experience of both co-ed and
single gender programs and we find that
the young women that are in venturing
they like being part of the Boy Scouts
of America right now men can be in
sororities women can be in fraternities
so what's I mean everything to
gender-neutral Boy Scouts here's the
problem do boys learn in a particular
way they're also a little goofy and
ganglia believe me I was just raking the
lawn with two of mine at five o'clock
and but they don't want to know it but
they don't want girls to watch them as
they blunder through these skills it's
better if they're on their ass I'm sorry
that's works out better I understand
girls don't want to just crafts all day
but give the boys their safe space I was
a girl I was I was I had a pattern I was
sowing my own clothes doesn't don't I
look like someone who do you look like
my mother tried to get me to do all that
stuff I'm like I'm going to play kick
balls don't even think about it